are you all drinking beyonce's piss yeah
no no no no no you just said oh you
already said yes you say yes yeah you're
right yes you're locked in wait are you
are you in a relationship with her i
thought you said my wife
yeah you said beyonce okay if you're if
it's to be her girl
her man or girl whatever she wants me to
yeah
you simping you said yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey
how to be honest this girl bro i'll be
beyonce's girl i'll be a kept woman for
beyonce
500 million yeah i'll do that i want to
be outside look at me 100
assuming we're all single yeah would we
drink a hot cup of beyonce's piss
this is coming from kevin gates by the
way just for coffee cup oh shout out to
kevin gates that guy's jesus yeah um i
prefer chilled
yeah like a repo like a reposado yeah on
the rocks i would go oh no if i could
have it on the rocks dude yeah oh no
it's late in a splash or like a whole
full cup what do we do can you mix it
with anything is it weird i want to
start drinking
like i literally got a feeling i was
like we should have drink
a splash of cranberry juice maybe some
red bull nah you can't mix them in
anything you can yeah don't don't mix
don't mix yo i heard urine can have like
um healing things
i said that to my wife when i pissed all
over my ass and she got a jellyfish bite
yeah and heals for jellyfishes yeah when
i dumped a hot piss on her ass
to save her from a jellyfish which still
has a [ __ ] uh
scar from it
yeah enough soon that's on you bro is
that normal jellyfish things like they
laughed yeah yeah
really i'd just be saying that [ __ ]
though i'm gonna be honest with you
bro but i think that's on you why do you
do more to you guys so if i peed more it
would have burned her less
well i don't know yeah maybe pee or i
think you just got to keep peeing over
some other stuff i don't want to make
this guys i don't want to make this
about my wife and and my me saving her
and how i'm a hero i'd rather make this
more just about beyonce's urine are we
talking about a double shot of beyonce's
piss
ice
rocks
glass yeah sip casually twisty oranges
on it and a straw you want garnish you
want that you're not going to go on raw
we got to go wrong you can make it look
nice
martini glass you gotta come on you
gotta use some clad yeah you [ __ ] up
the flavor bro you gotta get into the
flavor of it it's like a whiskey hmm i
want her dehydrated low-key you want an
age i want her dehydrated i want that
[ __ ]
gatorade yeah i want that okay orange
gatorade shake and not stir right that's
it and don't i want her to shake first
then pee like shake him within her body
oh that's fire yes no
do that then you drop a hot piss
onto a rock
one rock one of the big blocks like yes
oh they chipped it inside the bar i
don't want to yeah i don't want to oh
yeah like they cut it themselves that
morning 100 and i want to hit the rock
and be like splattering out
cause problems i want the bartender to
be cleaning that [ __ ] up oh wow yeah
you wouldn't do bottled you would do a
draft or i would do like a like a
pulling spring with a sport top
do you like a sport top only if it's
beyonce's piss that's that's an
exception feels more lifelike yeah i
streamed at your face you know that's
why i don't like a sport top i really
don't like a sport because it reminds
you too much of piss it just feels like
you're sucking on this nipple thing like
it feels too weird to me and you also
got like squeeze it squirt it out i
don't believe in a sport top yeah the
issues when he's a kid
same reason i don't like an over easy
egg some deep-seeded [ __ ] over-easy egg
is too [ __ ] to me slipping off semen
bro like what is it everybody's over
easy this one is over easy that's like
when it's super slippery in the middle
oh like the pure yolk untouched yeah
yeah exactly yeah it's just you're
slipping on breakfast and [ __ ] you ever
do that
i
love
a loose egg yo no you cannot be like
yeah
i'm not done yet be done though
pause though you see how he eats eggs
on the plate and i dip it into that
that's right that's fine no that's what
i'll do that's wildness i'll do that
that's fine do that with a burger yeah
oh i put i want that [ __ ] dripping on my
burger actually okay cause egg tastes
good with other [ __ ] like an egg on top
of avocado toast or whatever
by itself is is wild that's my point
this guy
every day at the first three years of
the podcast used to eat
two deviled eggs
[Laughter]
but but in all seriousness going back to
your uh issues with liquid or over easy
oh the egg i'm just saying like with the
egg
you have an aversion to it because it
reminds you of semen yes and i don't
know why that's in my head that i know
what semen feels like but every time i
eat egg i go this is it that's mad gay
bro what is it you eat over easy eggs
you eat over easy eggs
yeah but you're thinking about sea but
every time you eat an eggs right well
now you are also no i'm not yes you are
next time you have an overeasy egg just
think of me
eggs
[Laughter]
okay okay here's something you mentioned
that egg tastes great with other things
yes but not by itself okay
salt
yeah
put it on something
yes
unbelievable incredible makes it it
extracts all the flavors makes the
flavor so much better it's the best
thing you ever tried like
by itself you just described all
seasoning it's just all seasoning yeah
all of that hold on
my wife made a marinade
puts the chicken in the marinade yes
uh-huh
i tried some of that marinade yeah keep
going
it was just i couldn't eat it yeah
after letting it sit in the marinade and
then cooking the chicken
the chicken had so much flavor yeah it
was unbelievable what it was
unbelievable
you drank the marinade after it had the
raw chicken no right before prior
that's a lie that's a big [ __ ]
you got [ __ ] salamander right now
you're full of it guys guys another
thing okay
he's gonna describe more seasoning
that's all he's doing is yo yo anytime
you have spice by itself no good have
you even eaten by itself the whole time
what is that
have you been doing spice myself the
whole time this is why british people
didn't bring spice back from india they
went they went to india spice all
seasoning okay butter right
you take a bite of butter it is not yeah
it's super bad i've done that butter
alone is i not were you one of those
kids stuck on this thing yeah that's
just
yo that is weird
why don't you get everybody not butter
by itself unsalted
nah
nah so is den bites not by itself
someone ate butter in my house and my
mom measured all of our teeth to see who
did it that's a true story
all of your teeth
she took the bite mark out of the bunker
she was like come over here i got to see
if it was your teeth that took the bite
or if it was emily you took a bite
that's a true story bro
and you got like seven brothers and
sisters so it's mad measurements we did
the lineup we did a whole lineup who was
it bro it wasn't me but you would tell
my teeth would take that whole [ __ ] out
hold on so wait who was it i think it
was emily
oh my god that is hysterical
she made you bite another thing
how does she measure this
butter not enough she just kind of held
it up i was like yep it fits like when
you measure keys but you kind of just
like hold them up to each other you know
i mean that is crazy seems like a very
inexact science too what happened to her
what happened to her for that she got
they killed her
that's true gunshot to the head like you
said okay so discipline is important bro
yes discipline is very important
okay fact last food thing okay this is
it then i'm hanging out with blister
peppers bro you feel like you know what
i love about food man i'm out here in
the world okay
son this is why they didn't bring spices
from india i'm telling you british
people went to india and they were like
yeah this tikka is not really that good
we don't like it they're like well how
are you eating they're like spoonfuls
yeah that's what we're doing
mixing with water
no yo you think saul is crazy pepper was
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
what [ __ ] is this berserk bro like also
like sometimes my girl would do this
fancy [ __ ] with she'll like take salt
and pepper wow
bay leaf bro and just leave it in the
sauce and this is a crazy thing you
don't even eat it
it's in there sometimes you do and that
[ __ ] tastes hollywood
no
you're not supposed to eat it you're not
supposed to eat it you've been eating it
the whole time you ate a real one it's a
real one
i do think indian [ __ ] is like you'll
not eat it what do you mean you eat a
bay leaf do you ever eat the bay leaf
sugar we don't know what to eat and not
eat it's in the pot is edible
everything thank you
and we've been cooking with bay leaves
heller come on you don't waste nothing
like a [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] called
nut mig
yeah yeah i think i ate that one
yeah what do you think the rikers yeah
he hated the rikers it was on the floor
all over the place
nutmeg yeah not about vanilla vanilla
expensive no one talks about that yo but
also nobody talks about
vanilla
distinctly different flavor from vanilla
yeah
oh this is like a mandela effect thing
is it yeah i don't know how that applies
yeah but
continue one of you know it's changed
flavors over time vanilla has shifted i
don't think it's mandela effect though
it is it is because as a kid you think
oh it's bearing stained bears and i was
actually berenstein bears you know what
i mean what the [ __ ] is going on here
you know about dell effect
you know whatever mandela effect is no
it's proof that we're living in a
different dimension he's doing too much
there's a multiverse thing i don't know
if you heard this we all for a while
thought nelson mandela was dead it
wasn't a thing somehow we all just
believed it and he wasn't dead and then
another example is do you remember that
book that we had as kids the berenstain
bears
it's actually the berenstain bears none
of us know that we all just call it a
bear and there's a bunch of things like
yeah and vanilla used to taste different
when you were a kid and now you taste it
you're like that's not vanilla in all
seriousness
are we wrapping this up yeah i'm
drinking beyonce's pee you would yeah i
think it would give me healing powers
it's an honest question do you think if
you you know those like purifying straws
that they give to people in different
countries where they need like water
life straws you think you have one yeah
in my uh god damn it dove in la we had
earthquake kits earthquakes the scariest
thing that exists on the planet
earthquakes give that to somebody who
actually needs it yeah man
do you think you could drink pure urine
out of a life straw and it's just water
yeah
that's a great question actually wait a
minute it's just water or could you just
drink urine out of a straw
[Laughter]
i missed the question wait
what were you asking were you asking if
how do you have fun on like a weekend or
something like that yeah you get the
sport cap throw some pee in there you're
having a party no i'm saying you got a
life straw that can now it purifies all
the way this could solve the water
crisis you're gonna talk you literally
drink out of like uh so they'll give it
to someone with salt water why you got
to be urine why don't we just do it with
salt water because duh you could do it
with salt we're trying to have fun i
thought i thought my question is could
you do it if you this is what the
company ceo should do as proof he goes i
believe in my product so much
i'm going to have my friend pee in this
cup beyonce maybe and i'm going to drink
it with the livestream that's a win-win
and it's going to be water and if it's
not water it's even better yeah he could
do that as like an actual promotion
and i want to do it on this show
oh that's [ __ ] good we're going to
get a lance right now we're all going to
pee in it
i'm going to drink the answer's no
because that life straw removes like
it's an antimicrobial that doesn't
remove the salts from pee and all that
oh it just removes the microbes the
microbes all the stuff that's pretty
cool but the sultan pizza isn't bad salt
is amazing
that's the best part
fans like no one here doesn't like salt
i know it can't change the ph of the
water so it's going to taste like peeps
so what do they do if they give them to
someone in a country where they need
water
like what are they what is it good for
if it's just slightly worse water yeah i
got water bro
think about how much water i have bro i
turn my faucet on it's unlimited water
unlim but not even that just dig down
it's it's underneath right
go to the ocean figure it out not even
that like if you go down eventually you
get water right
sometimes
when do you not you're on a mountain in
the desert you're on a mountain i think
in the desert they got that [ __ ] bro
yeah how do you think cactuses are
living now
that's not from that yeah that's from
the moisture in the air at night but
that's how like if you take salt water
and you heat it and then the
condensation that goes on like i'm gonna
suck and you try to say [ __ ] and then he
knows the real reason
i should be cutting the legs out from
underneath why can't i drink peas you
need to get the legs cut bro why can't i
drink piava straw
look you can
you're gonna be judged by society for it
but i don't think that that should stop
i'm not gonna put it on my icloud or
something crazy i mean